all right the violent gang ms-13
unleashing new havoc yes this time in
Houston police say they arrested one of
its members after he kidnapped a 14-year
old girl and the suspect led them on a
high-speed chase across an interstate
and this all happened yesterday went on
for 30 miles and it didn't end until the
suspect Lubin Smith Reyes Sanchez ran
out of gas and surrendered
police say the kidnap victim was not in
the car during the chase and is okay
well critics claim that the Trump
administration is targeting ms-13 to
demonize immigrants for you know
importing crime statistics though do not
lie here's what the New York Times says
there are now 10,000 ms-13 gang members
in the United States and new reporting
by The Washington Post over the weekend
reveals how ms-13 is essentially taking
over one High School in Suffolk County
New York
police say the gang has committed 27
murders in the area all since the wave
of unaccompanied illegal immigrant
miners began arriving in 2013 joining us
now a man is on the front lines of the
fight against ms-13 Jay Lanham he's been
great on radio - is a director of the
Northern Virginia Regional gang task
force Jay you know the Washington Post
is like finally really on to this I
think they're reporting on what's
happened in Long Island which is
stunning a parent of a young woman who
was murdered by ms-13 two years ago came
on our show recently this is what she
said I'm feeling the loss of my daughter
I feel it every day
there's not a day a second that I don't
think about my daughter and um they just
don't understand the pain of a parent
losing their child to this gang violence
and this that was the mom Evelyn
Rodriguez was at the State of the Union
with the president tell us the real
situation as you see it in Northern
Virginia communities were you operated
these were middle-class fairly safe
communities when I moved here in 1986
it's a different world now absolutely
and the influx of these gang members
especially ms-13 into the Northern
Virginia area has just overwhelmed the
resources in the area the violent crime
has just been unheard of unlike what
anyone would expect to ever see they
kept their violence with machetes which
you can just imagine my Shetty's that's
their favorite weapon of choice you
could just imagine the brutality that
exposes to the body and when you see
when you see the results of this open
borders allowing these unaccompanied
minors into the United States we have
five thousand just in just in the New
York area of their five thousand
unaccompanied minors as you pointed out
before I think they're prime targets for
ms-13 recruited are they not absolutely
and we've seen that over the last two to
three years in the amount of violent
crime being committed by juveniles which
we didn't used to see so there have been
so many of these kids that have come
into the community they're scared to
death they're put into school some of
them don't even read and write their own
and their own language thank you and
these gang members know this they prey
upon them they exploit the weaknesses
the lack of a family structure
relationship issues they exploit all of
it
do you know only 4% of the unaccompanied
minors who've come into the United
States during that Obama wave only 4%
have been deported and when they this
first happened you remember what Barack
Obama said you're not going to be able
to stay here that was his original
comment but everybody stayed here so we
have thousands upon thousands of
previously unaccompanied minors kind of
rolling around the United States some
with sponsors some not and not all of
them are gang members
obviously but let me let me show you
what is happening in Texas where we had
this high-speed chase the Texas Public
Safety Commission has listed the most
lethal gangs in Texas and it says this
is last July the report that came out
here they are tengo blast it's another
gang like predominantly Latino gang the
Latin Kings has been around for years
Texas Mexican Mafia another horrific
gang and ms-13 ok ms-13 is number four
deadly because of the cartel membership
in the cartel connection to these gangs
tell us why that drives the violence
well it would ms-13 started because they
were protecting themselves from Mexican
Mafia now we're finding they tend to
work with the Mexican Mafia because the
cartels are pushing the drugs across the
border including the heroin and the
fentanyl and they're working together
Mexican Mafia mess 13 and even outlaw
motorcycle gangs to distribute these
drugs throughout the United States so
drugs are a huge part of this how big is
human trafficking and ms-13 it's large
it's difficult to prosecute and what's
unfortunate is most of these girls
involved are brainwashed and they don't
see themselves as victims and it's a
hard it's a hard case to prosecute and
to investigate because of that reason
and and how did the police who many
times are understaffed overworked
underpaid and they're going up against
this one of the most brutal gangs in the
world not just in the in the world it's
it's difficult but so ridiculous this
has happened it is these beautiful parts
of the United States Suffolk County
bedroom community in not--you New York
Northern Virginia Gaithersburg Maryland
I mean these are these are I came it was
like middle-class safe communities it's
a fact ms-13 is the fastest growing gang
in the United States and the propensity
for violence is very high and by the way
President Trump specifically called them
out over the weekend when he did that
rally in Pennsylvania I'm glad he did
keeping that issue front and center Jay
thank you so much